A new opinion piece in The New York
Times speculates
that Taylor Swift
may be a closeted queer person.
And in the piece, editor
Anna Marks points to possible
LGBT Q A Plus references
in Taylor Swift's
songs and performances
as a signal of queerness.
However, Swift has said in the past
that she does not identify
with that community.
Some have found it unusual
that The New York Times would publish
such an article.
CNN's Oliver Darcy joins us
live with more details on this.
Oliver,
I mean,
how unusual is it for The New York Times
to publish this piece?
I mean,
it's something that you wrote about
in analyzing
why The New York Times went here.
It's very unusual.
I mean,
you do not see major news organizations
like The New York Times
publishing lengthy
you know,
this was a 5000 word opinion piece
questioning the sexuality of someone
known, nevertheless,
the sexuality
of someone like Taylor Swift,
a prominent, obviously cultural force.
But that's what they did this week.
They published the story
in the opinion section
questioning her sexuality,
even though Taylor Swift in the past
has come out and said
that she is a straight
ally of the LGBTQ community, that she is
just trying to show support
as they come under attack
in recent years.
And so that's what's led
to a lot of
criticism of The New York Times,
including from
some of the singer's associates.
I've learned that they are not pleased,
to say the least,
with The New York Times.
One of the associates telling me, quote,
Because of her massive success
in this moment,
there is a Taylor Swift
shaped hole in people's ethics.
This article would have been allowed
to be written about Shawn Mendes
or any male artist with sexual,
and he has been questioned by fans.
There seems to be no boundary
some journalists won't cross
when writing about Taylor,
regardless of how invasive
untrue and inappropriate it is.
All under the protective
veil of an opinion piece.
That's from one of the people
close to the situation
over in Taylor Swift's camp.
Now, The New York
Times is not commenting.
They're not directly responding
to some of this criticism,
but they have pointed to
what Anna Marks,
the editor who wrote this piece,
actually wrote in her in her in her piece
preemptively addressing
some of the criticism Marks wrote.
I quote,
I know that discussing the potential
of a star's queerness
before a formal declaration of identity
feels to some too
salacious and gossip
fueled to be worthy of discussion.
I share many of those reservations,
Marx wrote.
But the stories that dominate
our collective imagination shape
what our culture permits artists
and their audiences to say and be.
Every time an artist signals queerness
and that transmission falls on deaf ears.
That silent signal dies,
and it goes on to say, Recognizing
the possibility of queerness
while being conscious of the difference
between possibility
and certainty keeps that signal alive.
Now, obviously,
associates close to Taylor
Swift don't feel that's justification
for publishing this lengthy piece.
And now it appears there's some bad blood
between them
and the paper of record Fred.
Well, The New York Times,
as you mentioned, Wiley
and a marxist responded,
The New York Times
almost has to, doesn't it,
Because there is criteria
measured as to what should be published.
I mean, this is The New York Times,
after all.
So there has to be
that kind of explanation as to why.
How beneficial
what what's the objective here?
And then for the writer as well.
The question still remains, why?
What does this mean and what's the
what's the objective here in publishing
something like this?
Yeah.
And the Times right now,
I mean, they're staying silent.
They have not addressed this.
You're not seeing an editorial leader
like the head of the opinion section
come out and justify
why they felt
they needed to publish the story
or why they felt
it was newsworthy enough to really break
general rules and questioning
someone's sexuality
and speculating about it
in The New York Times.
You know, The New York Times
is the paper of record.
And so
usually their standards are a lot higher
than other news organizations.
In this case, they did something
most news organizations would not do,
but they're not defending it.
They're just pointing right now
to what Marx wrote,
what I just read to you
defending the reason
for publishing that story.
Of course,
it will be intriguing
in the days ahead
whether they do feel
the need to respond more directly,
especially now
that they're fielding criticism
from Taylor Swift's associates.
And
I mean, I've been reading it.
I'm just I'm trying to figure out
what the meaning is here,
because it does seem like it's it's mean.
I mean, it just seems like there there is
an objective to undermine or,
you know, even using
what it is to this association
as a criticism, as as demeaning.
And that just seems like
that would be met
with a whole host of emotions as well.
Yeah.
And you're not the only one
that's read it and come away with that.
You know,
The Times has been receiving criticism
for this piece
just just exactly because of that.
And again, it'll be interesting
to see
whether they do respond
to some of those criticism.
It's not every day that you have people
in the orbit of someone like Taylor Swift
criticizing the Times so, so sharply.
Hmm. All right.
Oliver Darcy,
let us know when you hear more.
Thank you so much.